today I like to think I'm serving
recently divorced but back on my feet
realness Tigers and Rizzoli because no
no you know your life is different now
it is Friday here on my channel and
lately I've decided that Fridays are
going to be for commenting on your
comment so let's do that let's sort of
work twitter.com the platform for
posting words Leo the Chihuahua new
person diverse devices probably the June
that when a new person comments someone
my social media platforms I grazed the
crap out of them were welcome to the
it's great family I used to hate people
but now I great people because by being
mean when you can be done how do I
notice a new person I don't know I just
guessed
aka everyone's a new person the other
Chihuahua horlicks oh you're not bred
for survival at all whatsoever
well I clear the Chihuahua I'm crying
Civ so upset because someone
accidentally opened the window and the
breeze just blew Leo straight into the
garbage disposal you were good q did you
know that evil spelled backwards lived I
didn't until now so Wow Leo even though
physically you're not bred for survival
it also appears that emotionally you are
not bred for survival fun lane hope new
person person abundant laying off more
like lame joke lame
what a joker such a joke what's got two
cheeks and spell lane because she's the
butt of every joke that again he sends
supergroup when you gave up movie for
Lent for 30 30 movies on sale on Amazon
you have to support the squad yeah Lane
I don't think you're an ass anymore
you gave up movies for Lent people are
still giving up things for Lent this is
a fun concept you give up things leading
up to Easter to honor Jesus Christ
originator of the cinched waist but hey
Lane thanks to the head stuff if you
guys haven't already downloaded dirty 30
movie I think it's on sale on Amazon
according to Lane but that's incorrect
information well we all know that Lane's
banana even more leaf bless you her
super troopers and even more leaflet
more like even more leaves just leave
more leave leave more take your whole
body out of this area leave more human
groups I'm glad I enjoyed podcast
because not too deep is making like bad
morning much better thank you so much
great syllabic you're welcome thank you
for listening to not too deep which is
nice
six episodes of this podcast if you guys
didn't know the link is down below you
can listen to it for free on iTunes and
SoundCloud or you can watch full
episodes on the fullscreen platform and
this like season of the podcast we've
had some amazing guests that have told
some of the most hilarious stories Lilly
Singh is on the episode that's up on
full screen this week and Megan ranks is
episode just went up on sounds on iTunes
and both are hysterical so please go
check them out and that's the inflection
in which that sentence ends late geek
numers nippers diversion uplink peace
more like you know else's up late geek
you Bona your group love cleaning noise
and computers caked in makeup well the
wind-ups have the product for you
seriously Google electronic voice oh
thank you for the heads up possible
advertising for Windex box now let's go
to instagram where i post photos
Accio multi fandoms new friends new
virgin birth national defense like Akio
most I found wrong
you stupid you filled Pete you must be
you may see your boy I love it but also
you so would ask to speak to the manager
right now yeah that's the fun repetitive
comment that I've gotten on my new
haircut is that I look like a soccer mom
that wants to speak to the manager and
you know what that's right because the
managers your dad and you told us bull
and I speak I mean school this haircut
makes me want to sleep with your father
salmon or Newport super super fan or a
more like fan or not fan
I'll take knots and for ten thousand
thank you what is what I want your words
can't [ __ ] wait to meet you at VidCon
Europe you silly dumb dumb me too guys
I'm going to Amsterdam for VidCon in a
couple weeks will you be there and if
you are will I meet you
oh no I wasn't missile haven't even
gotten to Europe yet and I'm already
assimilating as awful slightly vague
European UK accent that aside I can't
wait to see your guy Maria is about
seven new person to work new partner
Maria is about seven more like s 12:7 we
are they now probably still wild and
fulfilled in their creative endeavors
you're rude where when can we buy you
the amazing shirt this is a comment left
on this Instagram photo where I posted
the shirt I made that is the captain
trihard and yeah would you guys be
interested in that as future potential
merch if so please let me know in the
comments down below
eggs now it's going to usually that's
where we are right now
Michelle Urban new person
person-to-person Michelle urban more
like Michelle urban dictionary dude
super sure is literally killing my eyes
this whole entire video laughing my ass
off I know I'm sorry where the strip
shirt that did this weird effect on
camera last week and a lot of you are
saying that it make you really dizzy but
I'm glad the Michelle seemingly
optimistic point of view about this I
mean my shirt murdered her eyeballs but
she's laughing her ass off at the end of
the day she won't have eyes or an ass
relatable as well kevin vanden person
person person Kevin ban more like
Michael Mini Cooper duper Bruce
transpose mu plus great people good day
and a plus light misogyny plus the
ability to comment directly on light
misogyny equal today and every day on
the Internet Maya near life new person
to first movers in Miami write more my
dear wife I'm going to make you my wife
if I believed in the concept of marriage
as something for me to do in my life to
feel full and old here we grew last time
I was that early Justin Bieber was still
14 so what you're telling me it's been a
long time since you've clicked on my
video right away should I feel good or
bad about it
how old is Justin Bieber he's 23 so it's
been nine years the mayor since you've
been this early Wow almost a decade and
I don't know if I should feel good or
bad I feel confusingly neutral
thank you for this sensation like mgtv
new person-to-person version like mgtv
more like with Justin for Mike might get
to vagina
no way not now not never you all I want
to do is get drunk and sing wrong [ __ ]
karaoke with great that sounds like a
pretty good time put that on your bench
before Madison
that we'll see what happened okay I'm
Everett commenting on your column say
thank you so much for commenting across
all my social media platforms I'm at
great public if you ever wonder where to
find me if you like this video give it a
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to this channel
some people have been commenting that
when they checked they didn't realize
that they have been unsubscribed to this
channel so go check it out for yourself
to make sure that you're not missing a
possible Monday Wednesday or Friday
video than that I don't know
Haley's tone it your friends new person
new person Bailey telling it more like
Bailey stalling it down your boo-boos I
never thought I'd be so happy about
someone telling me I'm full [ __ ] but one
grace does it I'm like yeah maybe I am
yeah maybe you are this has been a
really nice exchange thank you